welcome to the Google cloud platform
education series my name is Jeff Davis
and in this session we'll discuss
building high performance scalable VM
environments on Google compute engine
we'll be doing a moderated Q&A
throughout the session so feel free to
submit your questions with the ask your
question here field at the bottom of
your screen let's get started
here's our agenda we're going to begin
with an in-depth demo where we build the
necessary infrastructure to support a
fairly sophisticated application this
will illustrate all of the key features
within GCE and give you an idea of how
quickly and how easily you can build a
robust scalable high-performing
infrastructure we'll then go ahead and
talk about the wide range of GCE
features giving more details on the
features that we demonstrated and
talking about some other capabilities
that may be useful in your applications
for your particular use cases I'll spend
a few minutes describing how best to
find information as you're doing
research after today's session and
you're exploring GCE
on your own we'll talk about strategies
for determining how well GCE applies to
particular challenges or particular
computing workloads that you're looking
to move into the cloud and as I
mentioned we'll be doing a rolling Q&A
so feel free to keep those questions
coming so let's dive into a demo so
we're gonna start with an application
run by a company called better dev do
this is the be dev squared
system it's a learning management system
that allows employees all around the
world to find useful tidbits provided by
other developers and get up to speed on
the newest technologies you can see down
here that you can easily take a look at
existing learning paths this information
is pulled from a database of plans or
playlists of modules that developers
would find interesting on particular
topics you can find individual modules
so for instance here's a series of
modules on how to teach the newest
Google Cloud
platform class as well as something
about mantas which we'll look at in just
a moment you can also look at your
learning activity and your
accomplishments and where you are in
your performance against various plans
so if you click through to one of the
modules you can see that it's a small
micro learning nugget it has some text
and it has most importantly a video
segment these modules are created by
better dev employees and they're shared
with other better to have employees and
then they're put together into learning
plans or learning paths that people can
follow if you want to add a new module
you simply enter the title so I like
mantas and I'm the author and mantas
mantas mantas and then you can choose to
upload a video file what this will do is
actually upload the file to a back-end
and then create a new module record in
the database and this module will then
be available to learners throughout
better dev you can see that the new
module has appeared here and if you
click on any module again it shows you
something about mantas for instance okay
now some considerations when we are
running this learning management system
we have better dev employees all around
the world and so we want them to have a
good experience whether they're coming
from Asia or from Europe or from North
America we want the performance to be
good additionally we want the video to
stream well regardless of your network
connection or your device so those
videos that we upload they may start as
4k or 1080p videos but we're going to
want to transcode them into various
sizes so that we can do adaptive
streaming on the fly so let's take a
look at the architecture behind this and
then we'll actually show you how to
build it from scratch so here's the
architecture we have users coming from
North America from Europe and
Asia they all hit a single IP address
and this IP address is actually an
intelligent load balancer it will direct
users to the closest set of servers that
have capacity so you'll notice that we
have servers in US central in amia West
and in Asia East
we're running nginx servers here and
these servers deliver the standard user
interface to the LMS users if load goes
up we want this to actually scale and
give us multiple servers automatically
these servers are pulling all of the
configuration data the user information
the information about the learning paths
the information about the learning
modules out of a cloud sequel instance
when you create a new module you upload
media and that media goes into Google
Cloud storage and as I said before we
want to transcode that media so we want
to actually take the original video file
and we want to encode it at 480p 720p
and 1080p so once you dump it in cloud
storage we have transcoding servers
these are back-end servers separate from
the front end servers running engine X
and these transcoding servers will open
up the submitted file transcode it in
two different versions and store it in a
different location let's take a look at
how to build this actually in compute
engine so if we switch over to my list
of VMs in compute engine you can see
that I have a single back-end instance
that is currently running this is the
server that watches for new media files
to be submitted automatically grabs
those files and transcodes them and
stores them in a google cloud storage
bucket I also then have front-end
instances and you can see that I've got
three front-end instances I have one in
each of the regions I have Asia Europe
and US west so traffic will get directed
to each of these regions based on where
the traffic originates and whether or
not the target region has sufficient
capacity to serve the edges
requests I have a network load balancer
so if I go to the networking section you
can see that there is a single load
balancer that is configured this load
balancer provides the IP address that
we're hitting that then directs users to
the closest available resource we have
Google Cloud Storage set up and you can
see that we have raw media these are the
files that are submitted by developers
who are creating modules to share with
their peers and then we have another
bucket here and this bucket contains
transcoded video files these are for
instance the 480p the 720p and the 1080p
versions of videos that have been
uploaded by module creators there's also
a cloud sequel instance and this is the
database that is containing all of the
user learning paths and learning module
information so let's test before we take
this all apart and try to build it again
from scratch let's test the load
distribution sort of the geographic
routing of traffic and let's test the
auto scaling so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to bring up three test
machines I have a machine in Asia
Pacific a machine in Tamiya and a
machine in the US I am going to SSH into
each one of these in turn and I'm going
to do a little load generation on each
one
let's see let's write this one over here
so you can see that I've got three SSH
sessions I make this a little bigger so
that everybody can see it okay now again
the site that we're going to is the site
represented by this IP address so I'm
gonna grab that IP address and let's do
something simple let's use Apache bench
we're gonna do five thousand requests
we're going to have one simultaneous
session and we're going to just pull the
home page and I want to take that
command and I want to run it in three
different locations I want to run it in
asia-pacific I want to run it in the US
and I want to run it in amia now we also
want to see the effect that this load
generation has so what we're going to do
is we're going to look at our back-end
service configuration and this will give
us a nice little chart that shows us how
traffic is getting routed this shows us
the origination region of the traffic
and this shows us what back-end the
traffic is getting routed to okay so
with that what we'll do is we'll kick
off the traffic sessions on each one of
these and then we will go back to
back in services and what we should see
here now this is a graphical
representation that tells you about the
health of your back ends as well as the
traffic that's being directed to them
this doesn't really update in real-time
so I'm going to sort of force it to
refresh here but when we're done what we
should see is traffic to read
originating from three different
geographic regions and the traffic is
getting routed to servers also in those
regions
voila so you can see that we've got
requests coming from Asia going to Asia
we've got requests coming from North
America going to North America and we've
got requests coming from Europe going to
Europe you'll notice that we're already
actually reaching the you know the
maximum utilization that I've set on
these instance groups so that really we
don't want servers handling more than 50
requests per second and this is handling
67 this is handling 55 so what should
also happen here is we should see some
auto scaling so the instance groups will
actually add servers to deal with the
additional capacity requests so I'm
going to refresh my browser in hopes
that I can actually get you can see for
instance Asia has now scaled up to three
instances you can see that North America
and amia are scaling up to four this
says that there are instances that are
unhealthy this is probably just because
they're still spinning up and they
haven't started handling requests yet if
we go back to compute engine and we go
to instance groups you can look at the
instance groups and you can see that
they're scaling up currently so for
instance if I look at Asia
I can see that I'm averaging about 20%
CPU utilization across all of the
instances and that there are three live
instances responding to load if I go to
amia we should see that I'm now actually
up to four instances handling the load
again this is kept the CPU utilization
on average down to around 20 percent so
that's pretty cool what we have is a
situation where increased traffic drives
automatic scaling of my instances and
the traffic gets routed to the nearest
instance group that has capacity you'll
notice most of the stuff from Asia goes
directly to Asia occasionally there may
be requests where the Asia cluster is
determined to not have enough capacity
so it automatically routes it to the
next lowest cost Network path which in
this case would be Europe so that shows
scaling of the front end let's take a
quick look at scaling on the back end
okay so to check out scaling on the back
end what we need to do is we need to
create several new modules and upload
new videos the video transcoding will
eat all of the CPU for a back-end server
so if we do multiple uploads we're going
to need multiple back-end servers to do
the transcoding so the instance group
that we want to look at here is actually
the back-end group and we're going to
look at it by CPU utilization and let's
add a couple of additional modules
here's a demo module and I'm going to
pick a video file and upload that and
I'm going to create another module and
this will be demo 2 we'll pick another
video file and we can do one more demo 3
okay so now what we've done is we've
uploaded three new video files each of
which needs to be transcoded okay
you can see here's the first module if I
click on this this will actually take me
to a learning module that has an
embedded video this is the raw 1080p
video though on the back end what we
want to have happen is we want the
transcoding to occur if we look in the
bucket behind the scenes which you'll
see is there are new there's the chapter
1 2 & 3 videos and we want to have more
new transcoded sessions appear here so
you'll notice that this is my back-end
instance group and you can see now
instead of having one instance there are
three instances and you can see that the
average CPU utilization is on the order
of 80 percent 75 80 percent and so what
this has done is every time I upload a
new module that contains a video a
message goes to the back-end servers the
back-end servers kick off the
transcoding sessions the transcoding
sessions shoot the CPU utilization
through the roof because I've set a
limit on the amount of CPU utilization
I'm comfortable taking on when I go
above 60 percent CPU utilization it
spins up another instance and that then
pulls the next video for transcoding out
of the bucket and so this whole thing is
working for us now that looks great you
say Jeff terrific how hard is this to
build where you up till 4:00 a.m. this
morning putting this all together and
the answer is maybe but you won't have
to be it's actually quite
straightforward so what we're going to
do is we're going to start with two
bases what I've got is a back-end base
and a front-end base and these are
simply standard Debian images onto which
I have installed some software I I could
do that all from scratch now but it
takes a little bit of time to set those
up what I'm going to do though
is I am going to take each of these
pre-configured virtual machines and I am
going to create a base image from them
so you can see I don't want to delete
the boot disk when I delete the instance
I'm going to check each of those to make
sure that that's the case okay so what
we're going to do then is these two base
images that are configured to work just
the way I want what I'm going to do now
is I'm going to delete them but I will
keep their boot disks you always start
this recipe with a pre-configured
machine that works the way you want it
to then what you can do is create a boot
disk image so I'm going to create a new
image and I'm going to call this demo
front-end and you pick a source in this
case is an existing disc this is a disc
that I took off of a functioning VM and
I'm going to pick the efi base and I'm
going to create a new disc image now I'm
doing this all through the GUI you can
just as easily do this from the command
line or you can script it or you can
write custom management tools that will
automate this entire process for you if
you like so well that's create creating
the front-end image I'm also going to
create a back-end image and I'm going to
call this demo back-end and again is
it's going to start with a disc and I'm
going to go to the LMS back-end base and
I'm going to create that image so when
I'm done I should have two new boot disk
images created from the disks on two
functioning VM instances once we get
that up and running let me refresh this
you can see that my two images are being
created once I have these images I can
then create new VM instances that look
just like the original development
machines that I was working on and
that's great but I don't want to
build them one at a time I actually want
to have Google compute engine
automatically create these instances and
be able to scale up the number of
instances or scale down the number of
instances for me automatically so to do
that I need to create what's called an
instance template so there's my first
image down my second image is finishing
up so I'm going to go to instance
templates and I'm gonna create a new
instance template and we'll call this
demo front-end template and I'm gonna
pick a standard machine configuration so
one virtual CPU and 3.7 gigabytes of
memory I'm not going to do a clean
Debian install instead I'm gonna pick a
custom image and this is going to be my
demo front-end image and I'm gonna
designate the Scopes available so when
you boot up a VM you can designate
whether it has access to certain api's
we're going to go ahead and set that and
say you know what I need access to pub
sub I need access to cloud sequel I need
access to compute engine and I need
access to storage so where's compute
engine there we go so I set the scopes
and what this is basically saying is
anytime I boot up a instance based on
this template I want to make sure that
it's using this boot image I want to
make sure it's this machine type and I
want to make sure that it has access to
these api's so I'm going to go ahead and
create the template and then I need to
similarly create a back-end template now
the backend template requires a little
bit more configuration I need to
actually grab a startup script so I'm
going to look at one of the existing
instances and I am going to go find the
startup script so you can see here this
is the script that runs when the backend
instance server boots up so I'm going to
go ahead and create an instance template
and this one is going to be for the
back-end so we'll call it demo back-end
template same machine configuration
again I'm not going to use a standard
image I'm going to use a custom image
it's the demo back-end and again I need
to specify what scopes it's using and
it's going to be using cloud pub/sub and
it's going to be using the compute
engine API and it's going to be using
the cloud storage API and then I'm going
to specify which startup script it runs
when it boots and we'll create that so
what we've done is we took stock VMs and
we added our applications and that
created newly configured VMs we took
those VMs we copied their disks and made
images we took those images and now
we've made templates from the templates
we're going to make instance groups so
I'm going to create a new instance group
an instance group is a collection of VMs
that you can manage together and if
they're based on a template you can set
up auto scaling and load balancing quite
easily so we're gonna do demo front-end
North America and I'm gonna put these
all in the West Zone and I'm going to
use an instance template this is going
to be the front-end template and I'm
going to turn auto scaling on and I want
auto scaling to be based on HTTP load
balancing usage and I want to set a
minimum of one instance running and up
to five instances running okay so that
is my well actually we'll come back and
we'll do the load balancing in just a
second we'll start with CPU usage we'll
create this instance group now for the
front ends remember we had them globally
distributed so I'm going to create I'll
just create one more and this will be
demo front end
amia and I'm going to set this to run in
Europe there we go
and again I'm going to use the same
template and I'm going to set auto
scaling on and this is going to go from
one
two-five will create that so now I've
created two instance groups one for the
front end in North America one for the
front end and amia and I need to create
one more which is for the back end so
this will be demo back in we'll just
call that demo back end group and we're
gonna put that in u.s. West and we're
going to use the demo back end template
we're gonna set auto scaling on based on
CPU utilization from one to five we're
gonna create that so now what we have is
we have an instance group for the back
end and that runs in North America and
we have two instance groups for the
front ends one in North America and one
in amia if you look at the VMS what
you'll see is we have one instance for
the front end in amia one instance for
the front end in North America and one
instance spend spinning up for the back
end that's also running in North America
so you can filter here and you can see
these are the three instances that are
currently running again these are auto
scaling instance groups so they can go
up to five instances per but because
there's no load on them currently
there's only one running in each group
now the next thing that we need to do is
set up the load balancer right this is
the single IP address that's going to
send traffic intelligently to the right
back-end depending on where the request
originates so in order to do that what
we're going to do is switch over to
networking and in networking I am going
to click load balancing and I'm going to
create a new load balancer notice there
are three types of load balancers I'm
going to pick an HTTP load balancer you
start by giving it a name so this is
going to be demo load balancer you
configure a back-end service and to be
clear this is a back-end load balancing
service this is not the back-end service
for my application
so I'm gonna create the back-end service
and I'm going to call this demo
front-end load balancing and I'm going
to pick the North American front-end
instance group I'm going to say if I'm
at 30% CPU or if I'm at 80% CPU
utilization or 30 requests per second
then consider this group of servers to
be over capacity and then I'm going to
do the same thing for Europe and let's
see I don't need that and then I need to
set a health check and the health check
is going to be the front-end health
check so now my back-end service for the
load balancer is set up my host path and
rules I don't need to set my front-end
configuration this is going to be an
HTTP load balancer and it's going to use
ephemeral ports and I can go ahead then
and create the load balancer so while
this spins up in the background we're
gonna cross our fingers and hope that
when we're done we click on the IP
address for the load balancer it's going
to automatically determine which
back-end group of servers to send us to
we're going to go to that back-end group
of servers and one of those servers will
respond and if we generate load the
server instance groups should
automatically scale for us so let's take
a look so we cross our fingers and hope
that this actually is going to work
here's our global load balancing
pointing at our back-end instance groups
for the demo that's what we just created
we click on this and I'll be darned look
at that we can see that this is actually
being served by a demo front-end server
and it's being served out of the US West
one a zone and it has access to all of
the same information that the previous
incarnation of the application was using
because it's talking to the same sequel
instance in the background if I want to
generate some load let's say I want to
generate 5,000
sessions with 50 simultaneous sessions
I'm going to do that and I can do the
same thing in amia
and hopefully what we'll see is that
this generates traffic across our
back-end servers so let's go to back-end
services we can see that this is the
previous back-end service that we had
configured for the original application
this is our demo application if we click
on this what we should see is traffic
going to again we need to wait for it to
sort of update but we do see traffic
going from being originated in North
America and in Europe and over time the
visualization should get cleaned up and
you should actually see some of this
going to Europe let's take a look at the
instance groups real quick
and see how they're doing so we have the
demo instance groups they are all at one
currently they haven't needed to auto
scale yet but they will Auto scale as
necessary so in the course of about five
to seven minutes we were able to
essentially replicate the same sort of
configuration that we started with by
creating images from good virtual
machines taking images and creating
instance templates taking the instance
templates creating instance groups and
then front ending that with a network
load balancer ok and that gives us the
configuration that we talked about
indeed architecture slide so a lot of
details coming at you real fast but
hopefully that gives you an idea of the
range of capabilities and just how easy
it is to build high-performing scalable
globally distributed applications on top
of compute engine let's take a step back
and make sure that we can put all of
those individual examples in context and
look at compute engines overall
functionality
so by now it should be clear that
compute engine is a product that allows
you to run virtual machines a top of
Google's massive infrastructure so tons
and tons of computing cores of memory of
disk storage and of network globally
distributed and a tooling and work flow
that allows you to easily spin up one to
hundreds to thousands to tens of
thousands of VMs and coordinate their
activity and also intelligently route
traffic to the instances based on your
users needs we talked about virtual
machines there's a range of machine
types so you can go from one CPU to 64
CPUs you can go from roughly half a gig
of ram to four hundred and sixteen
gigabytes of ram and they've got a set
of different combinations of resources
so they've got four pre-configured sets
of recipes that are standard which is a
nice blend or balance between CPU and
memory they've got high CPU recipes
where that's like double the CPU for a
given amount of memory they have the
inverse which is high memory instances
and that's like double the amount of
memory for a given amount of CPU they've
got shared CPUs which are the least
expensive and lowest performing VMs and
then if none of these pre-configured
recipes work for you you can make your
own custom recipes and basically pick
how much CPU and how much memory you
want for every VM that you start up
you're going to need attached storage
and so GC offers standard and SSD
persistent disk standard disks are
rotating magnetic media and SSDs are
obviously really good for random i/o
kind of operations disk options whether
they're SSD or persistent offer you very
high availability and durability your
data is actually spread across multiple
disks so if a particular device goes
down your data does not get lost and you
continue to have access your data is
encrypted at rest so Google
automatically encrypts the data and
manages the keys if you work in an
industry where you're required to manage
your own keys you can also provide your
own keys and manage the encryption that
they optimize your disk performance so
if you get like a 10 terabyte volume
that's actually probably a bunch of
hundred gigabyte volumes and your data
is striped across that so you don't have
to do any software raid configurations
and they have snapshots which allow you
to easily backup disks and make copies
and then transport that backup maybe to
other zones or other regions to spin up
instances virtual machines range from
eight tenths of a cent to $4 per
instance hour you only get charged while
the machine is running and there are a
number of really customer friendly
pricing innovations instances are billed
on a per minute basis so for instance if
you use an instance for 11 minutes even
if it's a for an owl or an hour instance
you're only gonna pay roughly one-sixth
of that for you're only gonna pay for
the 11 minutes you use there is a
10-minute minimum but you don't pay for
the whole hour even if you only use a
fraction of an hour there are sustained
use discounts what this means is if you
use an instance 24 hours a day seven
days a week for the entire month you'll
actually get a 30% discount the more you
use it the bigger the marginal discount
becomes they even go so far as to give
you what are called inferred instances
so this is if you run one instance for
two weeks and you run another instance
for another two weeks they'll actually
stitch those two together and say oh you
ran an instance for four weeks and
they'll give you the discount and they
also have this thing called preemptable
instances which is these are instances
that you can get at a huge discount
they're 80 percent less expensive so you
only pay 20% of the price the Google
reserves the right to claw them back at
any time so what that means is if you
have a computed for instance where you
need 10 VMs running but you'd like a
hundred you can pay for 10 regular
instances and 90 preemptable instances
and if for some reason they take back 20
or 30% of those instances you still have
a bunch of instances that we're running
at a vastly reduced cost we showed you
during the demo boot disk images and
there are two types of images there are
public images and these are maintained
by Google or third parties and these are
clean operating system boot images so
Debian poor OS Ubuntu there are also
premium public images so like Red Hat
Enterprise Linux or sequel server on
Windows Server these you have to pay an
additional licensing fee on top of the
vm instance fees because you're using
third-party licensable software
generally what happens is you'll start
with a public image and then you'll
install your own software you'll change
the configuration and then you'll save
that as a custom image and that's what
we did in the example so we use our
custom front-end and our custom back-end
images in order to create instance
templates and then auto scaling instance
groups so that is customizing a public
image you can also use the new Google
via migration service this was just
launched in the last couple weeks and it
allows you to actually migrate live
running VMs from other environments to
GCP with no downtime so check that out
or you can also manually take say AWS
virtual machines export them as raw disk
images and then tweak them and import
them into GCP and then run those VMs now
in Google compute engine we had instance
groups and again an instance group is
simply a collection of machines that you
can manage together as opposed to
individually so these allow you to
easily add or remove instances you can
simply change the size of the instance
group and it can spin up additional
instances gives you self-healing on your
instances so if for some reason an
instance goes down and you have a health
check running the instance group can
determine that that instance is no
longer is healthy it can shut it down
and then bring up a replacement instance
with the same configuration we saw auto
scaling and this can be based on CPU
utilization it can be based on requests
per second if it's HTTP load balancing
or it can be based on custom stack
driver metrics so you can basically see
how the machines are being used and once
they exceed an average utilization you
can add additional instances this also
scales down so if you have five
those transcoding servers and then
there's no more transcoding Tugu after
ten minutes it will start backing off
and shutting down instances we saw a
load balancing and we built an HTTP load
balancer which not only distributes the
load across multiple back-end instance
groups but it intelligently routes
traffic to the nearest or fastest
instance group as long as it has
capacity
there's also TCP and UDP load balancing
options available in GCE and then these
instance groups can be zonal or regional
so a zonal instance group is a set of
instances that are all in the same sort
of fault space that means they're all in
the same building in a data center it's
possible that that zone could go down so
power could go out or a network cable
could go down you can choose to make
those instance groups regional instead
and if you do that your instances are
spread across multiple zones which makes
it less likely that if there's an outage
in one zone that that's going to
interrupt service to your end users you
have a sophisticated range of networking
options available to you in Google
compute engine it automatically creates
a network for you when you create a
project that network has a variety of
subnets and those subnets are all route
it routed for you automatically so it
automatically generates these routes
that allow all of these discrete subnets
to talk to one another you can also
create custom routes as necessary the
firewall rules are super flexible so
basically you can say that instances
with particular tabs allow incoming
traffic whereas instances without those
tags don't allow incoming traffic by
default there are a half-dozen firewall
rules created for you but you can tweak
those and add as many as you want
you have the ability to create VPNs so
that your private IP ranges within your
company are considered to be part of the
GCP private address namespace or the the
routing happens between the two of them
so you can easily work in an environment
that bridges your GCP networks and your
internal networks again we talked about
load balancing and you also have cloud
DNS which is GCP hosted public facing
DNS if you wanted to do DNS on the cloud
in terms of managing all this you saw me
work primarily with the cloud console so
I did everything sort of manually as it
turns out all work that you do in
administering Google compute engine is
done through a standard set of API s and
when I'm using the console the console
is talking to those API s
I could also use a command-line utility
like G cloud or gsutil G cloud is for
working with compute engine resources
gsutil is for working with Google Cloud
storage resources all of these basically
talk to the backend API s there are
third-party utilities or you can write
your own custom scripts or applications
to manage your resources as well so the
question is given all of these
capabilities giving the range of
instance types given the instance groups
and load balancing zone and so forth
what use cases can you tackle and what
could you do with compute engine here's
one example for inspiration frame store
is a company that does 3d renderings and
video renderings and basically they use
compute engine for excess burst
rendering capacity so they have a big
render farm on site but occasionally
they need to have a whole bunch more
cores thrown at a distributed rendering
process and so they work with compute
engine and they can spin up to 15,000
cores at the drop of a hat this actually
allows them to dramatically reduce the
rendering time and that allows them to
do a ton of fast turnarounds so they can
actually be more creative as well as hit
deadlines more easily and they save
money doing it considerable amounts of
money relative to having the same sort
of capacity on site this is a big
example of the little example that we
did with the transcoding on the back end
of our LMS now after today when you
start working
with compute engine you may need to go
find answers to specific questions or
guides on how to perform certain
activities so let me give you a few
hints on where to look for additional
information start with search search is
your best friend so if you start with G
CP space and your topic of entrant
instance or interest so for instance GCP
instance billing will give you a bunch
of articles the top one or two links
will almost always be directly relevant
in exactly what you want if you're
trying to figure out how to use the
command line always start with g-cloud
compute resource so g-cloud compute
instances g-cloud compute instance
groups auto scalars whenever you want to
manage one of those pieces using the
command line where I as I was using the
UI you would look for the g-cloud
compute command and again it will give
you what you need the documentation is
actually pretty good typically when you
search you're going to end up in some
sort of a how-to guide or a QuickStart
but if you look at the breadcrumbs at
the top of the article you can actually
go up to the top where you'll see a
top-level table of contents and this is
relatively standard across all the
products so once you master this for GCE
for instance you can use it for App
Engine or Google Cloud storage or
whatever so there will be quick starts
and this is a very short exercise that
gets your hands dirty and gets you up
and running on the technology there are
how-to guides so this for instance would
have guides on how do you build an auto
scaler how do you create an image how do
you create an instance group how do you
create a load balancer and then there
are deep dives into api's
and concepts and so forth a few notes on
how to best evaluate how well compute
engine will serve your needs for
particular use cases in your environment
so the first thing to consider is when
you're trying to make a decision about
applying a new technology to business
opportunities you want to take it
seriously it's not hard but have a
process and follow the process
typically what we recommend to people is
that you start by defining some decision
criteria what is it that you need to
know in order to make a decision that
yes this technology will work for you so
for instance does it scale to meet our
company's usage needs is it easy to
configure can our existing systems
operational professionals get up to
speed within a couple of days once
you've decided what it is you need to
know then you figure out how to test so
you're going to take an existing use
case and generally you're going to
create a Minimum Viable Product that
emulates either something you're already
doing or something that you hope to do
and once you have figured out how to
test so what is it you're gonna build
then you do some research to figure out
exactly how to architect that on the
platform then you're gonna actually go
ahead and build it you also need to
decide who's gonna be on the team and
they're key players you need to have
somebody who's going to be responsible
for the architecture of the application
so for instance are you using cloud
sequel as part of the solution how are
you going to do load balancing where are
you going to locate servers you need
some operations people these are the
people who are gonna actually be
standing up the instances and managing
the configuration you need somebody
who's going to be responsible for
program managing and then reporting out
the results and then obviously you need
somebody in in the business side of
things to help with the decision-making
typically we find like one month per use
case is a pretty good time period so in
the first week you do your defining of
the criteria you recruit your team and
you agree on what you're gonna test in
weeks two and three you define your
architecture and you actually perform
some pre testing to make sure that you
understand how all the pieces work and
you're doing things right and then in
the last week we actually perform the
test consolidate the results and you
make a decision now obviously this
timeline will change depending on the
complexity of your use cases as well as
the investment that you've put in terms
of how many people are on the team this
could be longer or shorter but two to
three month trial period will give you
the opportunity to test a couple of
different use cases and make a really
intelligent decision of
how to apply GCE to your particular use
cases so hopefully that gives you a good
sense of how to go about evaluating
google compute engine for specific use
cases in your environment and that's all
for this session thanks for joining us
we'll be sending you an email that has a
link to code lab which allows you to try
out on your own some of the concepts
that we covered during this session we'd
also love to get your feedback so
provide that feedback on screen and stay
tuned for our next session